هذه الصور التي وصلتنا منذ قليل لزياره
مفاجئه قام بها رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
الى اوكرانيا وتحديدا الى العاصمه كياف
التي هي الاولى منذ اندلاع الحرب الروسيه
طبعا نشاهد
الرئيس يعني يدخل الى ما يعني يسمى
بالجدار التذكاري لقتل الحرب في ساحه
القديس ميخائيل فيكياف وسط اجراءات امنيه
مشدده
طبعا كان هناك تكتم اوكراني كبير والغاء
للعديد من
اللقاءات التي كانت مقرره بسبب هذه
الزياره
وكان نائب وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه تحدث
عن زياره لشركاء
مهمين بالنسبه لاوكرانيا
وحديث عن تقديم المزيد من المساعدات اذا
نشاهد بهذه الصور
زيلينسكي يرافق بايدن في جوله على شوارع
العاصمه الاوكرانيه
طبعا كان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن من
المفترض ان يتواجد في بولندا هذا الاسبوع
لمناقشه تقديم المزيد من الدعم الدعم
العسكري
لحلفاء اوكرانيا في مواجهه
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه